[Musique]
bonjour bienvenue au parlement européen
à bruxelles pour un nouveau numéro d'
europe hebdo et cette semaine on revient
sur le sacre de vladimir poutine
président russe a été confortablement
réélu pour un quatrième mandat
l'opposition a faibli a dénoncé des
fraudes électorales et un climat de vote
obligatoire et pour l'europe
quelles conséquences la russie de
poutine une présence inquiétante aux
frontières de l'union européenne la
russie de poutine qui soutient des
mouvements d'extrême droite en europe
comme joe big hongrie par exemple la
russie de poutine qui met en avant par
une propagande bien rodée toutes les
faiblesses de l'union européenne pour
mieux la déstabiliser point
d'interrogation faut-il être vigilant
c'est le débat l'europe hebdo trois
invités monjoin sur ce plateau franck
proust
bonjour vous êtes député européen
français à chef de la délégation
française du ppe parti populaire
européen qui regroupe la droite et une
partie du centre ici au parlement
européen pour vous a invité aussi car
vous publié cette semaine un rapport
fort intéressant sur les filtrages des
investissements étrangers en gros
comment protéger les entreprises
européennes un des appétits étrangers
notamment chinois merci d'avoir accepté
mon invitation guillaume balas bonjour
vous êtes nos députés européens français
du groupe des socialistes et démocrates
vous avez beaucoup travaillé sur le
dumping social ici au parlement européen
et en france vous contribuer à
l'émergence du mouvement générations le
mouvement de benoît hamon merci d'avoir
accepté mon invitation enfin il ya sec
saryusz wolski bonjour j'aime me lancer
vous êtes député européen polonais vous
êtes spécialiste des pays d'europe
centrale et orientale
merci d'avoir accepté mon invitation
d'abord les images retour son sacre de
vladimir poutine
il obtient son plébiscite réélu
président de la fédération de russie
pour un quatrième mandat mais
l'opposition dénonce des fraudes
électorales et l'empoisonnement de
l'agent russe sergueï skripal et sa
fille yulia continue de polluer les
relations entre la russie et le royaume
uni loris beau chaud
c'est sa quatrième élection
présidentielle et ça plus nette victoire
vladimir poutine n'a jamais été aussi
largement élu avec plus de 76% des voix
dès le premier tour
c'est six fois plus que le candidat
communiste arrivé deuxième je voudrais
lancer un appel à ceux qui sont ici
aujourd'hui à moscou et à nos partisans
sur l'ensemble du territoire de notre
pays
merci beaucoup pour ce résultat au
pouvoir depuis 18 ans 14 ans comme
président et quatre ans comme premier
ministre vladimir poutine est assuré de
rester au kremlin jusqu'en 2024
mais ce triomphe est contestée
l'opposition russe
rejointe par l'union européenne critique
des pressions exercées sur des électeurs
dans le viseur du principal opposant
inéligible plus de 2000 irrégularités il
y a d'abord les bourrages d'urnes et
vous voyez qu internet est saturé de
toutes sortes de vidéos à ce sujet avec
des gens filmés par les caméras
installées au plafond qui s'approche des
hurdes et y glisse un paquet de
bulletins de vote
c'est bourrages d'urnes se passe partout
dans le pays
exemple dans ce bureau de vote des
environs de moscou
un agent électoral s'empresse de glisser
plusieurs bulletins dans l'urne des
bulletins finalement annulé par la
commission électorale
pour vladimir poutine le plus dur
commence à l'ordre du jour une
stagnation économique mais aussi un
climat de guerre froide entre londres et
moscou
la crise diplomatique se poursuit depuis
la tentative d'assassinât d'un agent
russe sur le sol anglais
le 4 mars pour la première ministre
britannique c'est sûr la russie est
coupable de cet empoisonnement en
conséquence de cet acte épouvantable
contre notre pays notre relation ne peut
plus être la même
nous allons donc suspendre tous les
contacts bilatéraux de haut niveau
prévue entre le royaume uni et la russie
des accusations balayées par le
président russe nous n'importe quel
homme sensé peut comprendre que c'est du
grand n'importe quoi que ça n'a pas de
sens que quelqu'un en russie puisse se
permettre de faire de telles choses
juste avant l'élection présidentielle et
la coupe du monde de football c'est tout
simplement inimaginable autres fronts
sensible en syrie où les russes sont
présents depuis 2015 à la demande de
bachar al assad et au grand dam des
occidentaux
poutine voulait sauver le régime syrien
il a rempli son objectif et a fini par
s'imposer comme un acteur critiquer mais
incontournable sur la scène
internationale
[Musique]
voilà victoire de vladimir poutine qui
repart pour un quatrième mandat qui doit
le maintenir au pouvoir jusqu'en 2024 ce
que l'europe doit être vigilante en
profiter je crois que vous avez bien
utilisé le terme il faut être vigilant
et replacer je crois que cette victoire
de poutine dans
aime les gens qui ont de la force de la
persuasion c'est à dire que c'est
quelqu'un qu'on peut respecter mais qui
attend quelque part une identité
or ce qu'il nous manque à l'europe c'est
une diplomatie étrangère
c'est peut-être un manque de leadership
on a vu dans cette institution combien
quand la france a eu la présidence
européenne je pense à nicolas sarkozy
comment nicolas sarkozy face à vladimir
poutine avait réussi la crise de la
géorgie en 2008
gallas qui sourit à l'énonciation
nicolas sarkozy au nom veut pas rentrer
là dedans je pense que la sarkozie
malheureusement afin beaucoup résisté
pas très sûr l'admirent poutine alors
est-ce qu'il faut être vigilant on a
quand même je vous dis entière de
l'union européenne eca qui soutient des
mouvements d'extrême droite oui mais je
vous dis ma chien au nom des français
ils ont un rapport à la russie qui a à
peu près le même que qu'ils ont à
l'europe c'est à dire un rapport au
religieux il ya des fanatiques
c'est les pires en france qui explique
que poutine c'est fantastique c'est
l'alliance traditionnelle de la france
face aux germains j'ai entendu ça et
compris à gauche qui sont d'une
complaisance absolue
quoique fait poutine en fait c'est
formidable
et quand il est attaqué en fait c'est
comment dire là derrière les américains
et c'est bon il ya cela puis elle reste
les autres c'est-à-dire poutine quoi
qu'il fasse c'est le mal en oubliant
qu'en effet en chine et un type qui
vient de se faire élire à vie et là
personne n'en parle tout montre ça
normal
la chine inde et de relations
commerciales mais quoi que fassent
poutine c'est le diable donc il faudrait
juste avoir un rapport un peu rationnel
vladimir poutine moi est quelque chose
qui me dérange beaucoup
c'est que sur la sphère d'afrique sur
les kurdes
ce qu'on oublie toujours de dire là en
ce moment c'est que sillard dogan a pu
aller à free et notamment faire le
nettoyage ethnique
il est en train de faire c'est parce
qu'il ya eu l'autorisation de la russie
donc c'est un peu plus compliqué que
dire il ya l'otan d'un côté avec les
turcs et de l'autre côté il ya poutine
en réalité on voit bien que la russie
défend ses intérêts ça n'est pas une
démocratie libérale
donc nous devons être vigilants ferme et
évidemment ouverts comme nous sommes
avec le reste du monde
monsieur valls qui une chose est
certaine que les américains n'ont pas
influencé ces votes parce que même les
russes ne pouvait nous
pouvait pas l'influencé s'était pas à
l'élection c'était plébiscite dans le
meilleur cas navalni à la nuit faut-il
être vigeant il fallait être vie les
gens depuis des années ce que l'occident
n'a pas fait il fallait il fallait être
vigilant quand on essayait de vendre le
mistral à la russie
il faut être vie il fallait être
vigilant quand on fait de contrats sur
north stream 2 avec le russe
quant au lait permet de pénétrer nos
entreprises nos médias nos marchés
financiers j'espère que non mais
peut-être il est trop tard
c'est ce que voulait dire par là qu'ils
n'entrent is no russe dans lieu en
présence influence très forte sur les
processus démocratiques même c'était les
élections en france le break site les
élections en italie par tous les
éléments il craignait ce que sait faire
c'est comme ça dit mirko tina une
responsabilité dans la montée des
populismes en europe
oui très fortement il supporte pas
seulement l'extrême droite qui est
infiltré par eux y compris le front
national en france mais aussi l'extrême
gauche comme series ah non il est
présent partout par ses moyens ces
instruments qui vient de des temps de la
russie soviétique de l'état soviétique
et pendant des années des années
l'europe occidentale où l'occident en
tout entier rester aveugle et ne voulait
pas entendre ceux de l'europe centrale
orientale qui connaissait la vraie
nature de l' empire russe ou soviétique
et il est tard si notre tard aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que reproche selon vladimir
poutine à l'europe à l'union européenne
c'est quoi de se rapprocher trop de sa
sphère d'influencé
d'avoir intégré les pays baltes en 2004
peut-être une certaine forme d'ingérence
de l'europe sur un certain nombre de
conflits
regardez ce qui s'est passé en crimée
l'europe a bien réagi
les sanctions fermes les sanctions
fermes avec un embargo mais regardez
bien même sur ces sanctions le problème
c'est qu'on n'est pas capable de
maintenir sur des mesures dans le temps
regardez on a fait un embargo qui a eu
comme conséquence un embargo des
produits agricoles et on a mis en
difficulté tout le secteur de
l'agriculture moi qui suis un député
européen français notre secteur agricole
français a énormément souffert
donc je crois que il faut de la
lisibilité encore une fois ce qu'il nous
faut c'est une véritable politique
étrangère avec un véritable leadership
mais il faut surtout que l'europe se
fasse respecter
le gros avantage que nous avons
aujourd'hui on le voit bien c'est qu'on
est plus forts à 500 millions qu'à 60
millions ont regardé ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui chez nos amis anglais vous
avez parlé de cet empoisonnement en
parler on va pas verser dans l'espion
russe
je crois qu'aujourd'hui être isolé
représenterez face à de telles
puissances la russie la chine ou les
états unis un véritable danger mais
encore une fois lorsqu'on prend des
sanctions il faut avoir une véritable
stratégie une politique et vous savez on
ne respecte que les gens dont on craint
un petit peu le comportement est
aujourd'hui pour revenir à votre
question je pense que c'est une certaine
forme d'ingérence
monsieur poutine voudrait prendre ses
décisions sur le monde sur un certain
nombre de conflits ou de politique
étrangère à lui seul mais elle a tj de
déstabilisation après quelque part on le
voit indirectement ou directement c'est
pas un hasard s'il ya des bruits mon
collègue a parlé d'une influence russe
sur une élection américaine monde
on voit très bien qu'aujourd'hui les
influences elles sont multiples mais
encore une fois essayons je rejoins sur
mon collègue balasse il faut prendre
dans ce genre de chose de la hauteur et
ne pas juger trop vite et surtout éviter
les caricatures qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
on est soit dans un camp soit dans
l'autre sur la stratégie de
déstabilisation france ça pas marcher un
macaron a été élu il avait misé la
dioxine avait misé sur françois fillon
d'ailleurs à pas sur marine le pen sur
françois fillon début mai sur maryse le
même ça va marcher non mais toute façon
le fait qu'aujourd'hui
et des agents d'influencé russe y
compris ici en a pas se mentir comme il
ya des agents d'influencé jamais rien
comme la chine ne met une pression
aujourd'hui à l'union européenne très
importante on en prendra sans doute tout
à l'heure tout ça est vrai donc c'est le
reflet de notre impuissance à nous la
réalité c'est que si l'union européenne
avait aujourd'hui une politique un petit
peu cohérente sur ces sujets c'est grey
je prends l'exemple de syriza vous dites
syriza est un filtre il ya une affluence
aujourd'hui c'est très clair en grèce de
la part de la russie mais pourquoi est
ce que comme on a mis la grèce à genoux
bailly charge des alliances de revers
c'est comme ça que ça se passe et ils
ont été limite un moment de choisir en
effet de façon définitive la russie par
rapport à l'europe donc la question qui
se pose par rapport à nous c'est quoi
c'est d'avoir une politique est une
politique cohérente et notamment de
fermeté quand on a des intérêts
géopolitiques énergétiques qui sont
différents de ceux de la russie
on doit pouvoir s'affirmer et moi je
vais vous dire le grand problème c'est
que l'europe ça crie l'europe ça râle et
et après ça se couche et c'est ça et
c'est ça le grand sujet on devrait -
crier et moi râler et par contre moi se
coucher je pense que ce serait beaucoup
plus utile pour se faire respecter par
poutine aujourd'hui
et puis donc il yal'affaire de
l'empoisonnement de l'ex espion russe et
de sa fille pour londres il ya pas de
doute possible à c'est la russie qui est
derrière l'europe qui affiche sa
solidarité avec le royaume uni le
premier ministre polonais a déclaré être
tombé d'accord avec la chancelière
allemande angela merkel en visite à
varsovie pour que l'union européenne
donne une réponse ferme on écoute et on
réagit juste après
considérons qu'il ya des informations
sérieuses tran pointe en direction de la
russie
c'est à la russie de prouver maintenant
qu'il n'en est rien nous sommes tombés
d'accord pour dire que l'union
européenne doit donner une réponse ferme
et non seulement symbolique et nous
attendons de l'union que le sujet de l'
attaque russe figure dans les
conclusions du conseil européen
sk pas un double message dans cet
empoisonnement aux traîtres entre
guillemets le message c'est vous ne
ferez jamais en sécurité et au royaume
uni
vous êtes faibles on ne vous respecte
pas tous d'accord
deux messages si non plus c'est pas le
premier emprisonnement sur le territoire
de l'union européenne il y en avait ici
à strasbourg la à strasbourg il y en
avait à londres avec litvinenko avant il
faut être ferme ce que disent le leader
ça serait de arrêter le nord stream 2 2
inclure dans l'ain sanctions exclusion
de la russie de système swift tout le
reste
expulsion des diplomates le parc s'est
passé comme les descentes et dalida les
représailles et sa britanniques sont pas
assez fortes
ils doivent ça doit être une réaction
des liens européenne dans son ensemble
raid et le drame quelque chose qui me
trouble quand même mais vous l'avez dit
c'est pas quand même le premier espion
qui est tué sur le territoire
britannique je crois qu anna en est on
en décompte plus d'une dizaine donc à un
véritable problème de protection des
échanges d'informations et d'efficacité
parce qu'on n'arrive pas ce résultat là
par hasard une place moi je pense que le
problème c'est regarder la dépendance
structurelle aussi de l'union européenne
par rapport à la russie
la réalité c'est que en effet tout ça
peut être du cirque si jamais un moment
donné on ne se renforce pas par rapport
à la russie par exemple sur la question
énergétique
moi je suis toujours fasciné de voir le
nombre d'hommes politiques européens ou
d'hommes d'affaires européen qui
finissent finalement dans les filets de
gasprom d'une manière ou d'une autre
donc on voit bien là qu'il ya un
emmanuel todd un essayiste français
connus disait en fait il ya dix ans il
disait nous sommes déjà sous la
dépendance réelle de la russie en termes
politiques parce que il ya la dépendance
énergétique
donc là il ya un défi le défi c'est
comment nous nous rendons aujourd'hui
autonome de manière énergétique ça sera
meilleur d'ailleurs du point de vue
écologique pour y compris ceux dépendent
aujourd'hui de la russie d'un point de
vue géostratégique et ça pour moi c'est
un élément extrêmement important
autrement ce qu'est ce qui va se passer
moi je veux bien me voir madame merkel
en train de faire ce qu'elle est en
train de faire mais quand on connaît les
liens de l'allemagne et la russie par
exemple sur le plan énergétique
moi je sais que ça ira pas très loin un
double discours alors n'y a pas beaucoup
de volonté ans et c'est hyper important
ce que dit mon collègue wallace réunion
de l'énergie qui a été votée en 2016
maintenant il faut que ça se concrétise
réellement parce que plus on sera
indépendant et puis on saura se faire
respecter de la part des russes vous dit
en gros il faut une europe plus
puissante face à alors à la russie mais
on l'entend pas cette force de
résistance ni en france ni en allemagne
ni eux ni en italie alors c'est un peu
nos valeurs qui sont ils sont menacés
qu'est-ce qu'il faut il faut plus de
politique étrangère de sécurité comme
l'une plus de politique européenne de
défense de défense d'énergie pour
limiter justement la dépendance
vis-à-vis de pays tiers
on ne peut se faire respecter ne pas
avoir peur d'un pays tiers que si on
dépend pas d'eux pour des secteurs
stratégiques comme l'énergie
ça va de soi sauf qu'aujourd'hui
derrière le texte 2016
il y à des textes mais est ce qu'il ya
une réelle volonté politique
et qui dit volonté politique d oc
volonté budgétaire parce que la volonté
politique ne peut se traduire que s'il
ya une ligne budgétaire
le problème aujourd'hui je voulais dit
en introduction c'est que qui parle au
nom d'europe
est ce qu'il ya un véritable leadership
face à un vladimir poutine face à donald
trump à saint jean ping le problème il
est là c'est que aujourd'hui notre force
c'est d'être à 500 millions mais on
manque de leadership est cohérence et et
surtout de volonté politique de faire la
transition avec notre deuxième sujet
franck proust est ce que vous pensez que
russie a tous des médias russes basés en
france récemment est-ce que ça un
investissement étrangers indésirables
mais les médias font partie de ces
secteurs sensibles
je dis ça parce que vous vous voulez
publier un rapport intéressant comment
pousser l'union européenne à mieux se
protéger des investissements étrangers à
des rôles alors que la commission
européenne a mis sur la table à
l'automne dernier une proposition de
législation très peu contraignantes à le
parlement européen travaille
actuellement à sa propre position
c'est l'objet du rapport que vous
présentez l'idée c'est quoi alors c'est
d'accorder plus de moyens aux européens
pour éventuellement bloquer des
investissements
l'idée déjà sans parodier un écrivain
illustrant france marcel proust qui est
mon homonyme
c'est d'aller à la recherche du temps
perdu parce qu'on a parlé des grandes
puissances tout à l'heure les états unis
la chine le japon le canada tout le
monde a son système de filtrage le
problème en europe c'est que sur 27 est
à seulement 13 ans non et qu'aujourd'hui
on voit très bien qu'un investissement
qui est réalisé sur un état sur deux
états peut avoir une conséquence
économique sur une filière industrielle
et donc sur nos emplois sur un autre
étage vous prendre un exemple imaginer
qu'aujourd'hui une entreprise chinoise
investissent en bulgarie en pologne en
suède sur une entreprise qui fabrique
des rives est essentiel pour construire
des airbus s'ils ont le monopole dérivés
ils ont le droit devienne mort sur le
domaine aéronautique
idem quand j'entends le patron de
renault dire je fais une une stratégie
industrielle sur les véhicules
électriques mais je laisse le monopole
de la batterie aux chinois c'est un non
sens sur un plan économique parce que si
vous perdez le monopole des batteries
vous avez vous perdez votre votre droit
de 2,2 de pouvoir sur et bien les
différentes marques automobiles donc le
le but c'est d'avoir il ya par exemple
en france un outil qui avait été créée
en 2007 encore une fois sur nicolas
sarkozy repris par am
arnaud de montebourg qui vient d'être
rom dernier par bruno le maire
il y à un mois et qui met des secteurs
qui sont des secteurs dits sensibles
mais encore une fois le tout c'est de
mettre un outil qui soit pragmatique
efficace pour protéger l'ensemble du
territoire européen
parce qu'on voit aujourd'hui que les
intérêts et les secteurs sont liés on ne
peut pas bien se prémunir se protéger
que si on a un bon système de filtrage à
l'intérieur de son propre pays au palace
non mais moi vous savez ça fait 15 ans
que je combats l'espèce d'idéologie
dominante stupide européenne sur le
libre échangisme cette espèce de naïveté
qui ne profite en fait qu'aux riches
dans notre dans notre belle europe et je
suis très content qu enfin ce débat
puisse se serait je veux dire votre
rapport avec intérêt parce que on fait
n'importe quoi quand je vois qu'il ya
des
par exemple on parlait de la grèce qui
est acheté à peu près entièrement
aujourd'hui par les chinois par exemple
quand je vois intérêts non mes amis mais
quand je vois en france même des terres
agricoles achetées par des sociétés
chinoises et je dis franchement dans ce
cas là faut aussi remettre en cause les
accords commerciaux tels qu'on les
signent leur espèce de naïveté absolue
qui fait que par un libre échange sans
critères sociaux sans critères
écologiques sans critères stratégiques
où on autorise aujourd'hui les
investissements sans contrôle dans
l'union européenne est une folie or on
nous dit que ça va cesser monsieur
juncker nous a dit ouh là là mais ça va
cesser monsieur mac on lui dit oulala ça
va cesser le résultat c'est qu'on en a
jamais autant signer et qu'on va
continuer à en signer donc il faut que
ce débat émerge
il faut enfin que l'europe sorte de sa
naïveté coupable parce que c'est encore
une fois les populations les plus
faibles qui aujourd'hui souffrent le
plus de ce libre échange totalement
inégal qui est ciblé les chinois y la
dépendance excessive économique c'est
mauvais la dépendance politique c'est
pire
et ici je crains pas les chinois he j'ai
créé un russe j'évoque encore une fois
les north stream 2 c'est un meilleur
exemple de de nous et aurait être
aveugle à l' influence politique qui
vont avoir qu'ils ont déjà parce qu'ils
manipulent la scène politique européenne
et ils vont en faire vendredi l'uss sur
l'a10 mi-août il lé leadership vous
parlez des leaderships c'est pas dire
messieurs tel ou tel premièrement ça
doit être fait par l'union européenne et
pas par les capitales nationales avec
tout mon respect pour paris deuxièmement
c'est le manque de volonté politique de
se mettre d'accord les capitales forces
vont mutuellement de la concurrence je
me souviens de délégations française
allemande et autres qu'ils allaient ap
hm à pékin et ils ne feront toujours les
états existent bien évidemment oui oui
donc donc l'économie ne doit pas ne doit
pas prévaloir sur les raisons politiques
et stratégiques et aujourd'hui
c'est l'intérêt économique qui est
dominant égoïste d'ailleurs ce que je
voudrais c'est que les choses il faut
bien recentrer le débat
nous ne sommes pas contre les
investissements étrangers nous avons
besoin dans tous nos territoires d'un
moyen sûr nous sommes content rejoindre
ce que vous dites
les investissements étrange c'est à dire
ceux qui ne correspondent pas une
volonté économique mais plutôt à une
volonté politique et nous allons cible
aéronautique les médias voilà le big
data
les terres agricoles parce que derrière
les terres agricoles c'est la dépendance
alimentaire c'est la sécurité
alimentaire et énergie c'est
l'affectation l'énergie bien entendu
donc dans mon rapport on liste un
certain nombre de secteurs dits
sensibles qui peuvent mettre un remettre
en cause la sécurité nationale
liste qui peut être abondée puisque et
des secteurs qui étaient pas sensible il
ya dix ans qu'ils le sont aujourd'hui
d'autres qu'il l'était qui ne le sont
plus mais encore une fois je crois qu'il
faut marquer là la fin de la naïveté
européenne nous avons déjà commencé à
améliorer la situation
encore une fois l'europe doit à ce
qu'attendent nos concitoyens comme nos
entreprises aujourd'hui si une europe
qui agit une europe qui protège
il ya eu nomades qui a empêché à la
chine d'avoir le statut d'économie de
marché
il ya eu la révision de nos instruments
de défense et bien c'est pour moi c'est
le troisième triptyque avec cet outil
qui va faire en sorte de marquer quelque
part la fin de la naïveté européenne
parce qu'encore une fois ci il ya dix
ans les états parce que en fait le
principe de subsidiarité d'un état ne
sera jamais remis en cause c'est l'état
in fine et qui décidera l'investissement
pas mais ce que s'il ya dix ans quand on
a demandé aux grecs devant d'un certain
nombre d'actifs
est-ce qu'il n'était pas quand même
dangereux de donner l'accès la
méditerranée aux chinois il ya un moment
donné je pense que en ayant une bonne
collecte d'informations en ayant un
dialogue au sein du conseil on doit être
capable de se dire attention là il ya
des secteurs stratégiques
on doit pas laisser tout fernand
lafargue l'auteur dans le libéralisme
sauvage dont parlait monsieur balas et
aux balles à ce mot de la fin sur ce
thème
c'est très simple c'est que moi je suis
un farouche écologistes et je sais que
si nous ne faisons pas la transition
écologique aujourd'hui en europe
c'est aussi parce qu'on a cassé notre
industrie sur ce sujet et que
aujourd'hui nous sommes dépendants par
exemple de technologie
étrangères par exemple chinoise quelle
absurdité
alors que nous avons tous les ingénieurs
aujourd'hui en europe pour faire la plus
belle transition écologique au monde
donc il y a un lien entre la politique
économique et commerciale que nous
menons et les transformations
nécessaires dans nos sociétés ont besoin
sortons de la naïveté reprenons nous en
main allez on termine par notre rubrique
de fac chez king à la france toujours à
la pointe du féminisme havrais fossey
checkpoint réparer cette semaine par
guillaume goubert les droits de femmes
en europe en novembre 2010 est le
ministre français de l'éducation
nationale jean michel blanquer a affirmé
à france serait toujours à la pointe du
féminisme à la france sa galanterie son
romantisme de beaulieu et son féminisme
à la pointe
prenons tout d'abord l'un des droits
fondamentaux le droit de vote
remontons le temps en 1944 la france
accorde aux femmes le droit de voter
mais elle est loin d'être une pionnière
l'espagne l'avait accordé 13 ans plus
tôt au royaume uni les femmes de plus de
21 ans n'ont pu voter dès 1928
si on remonte encore plus entre 1915 et
onze pays européens ont permis aux
femmes de voter mais parmi les 28 c'est
la finlande qui décroche la timbale en
accordant le droit de vote aux femmes
dès 1906 à pas à la france et sa devise
liberté égalité fraternité et parité
dans le monde politique pas vraiment
selon un classement de l'union
interparlementaire la france est 14e
mondial avec 39% de politicienne dans
ces assemblées élues pas mal mais la
finlande et la suède font mieux avec 42
et 43 6% doit fermer dans leur assemblée
les hommes politiques français sont-ils
macho en tout cas un peu plus que les
hommes d'affaires français
l'hexagone est un des rares pays
européens où les conseils
d'administration des grandes entreprises
sont composées d'au moins 30% de femmes
la france est même en tête de l'ue avec
41,2 % soit 4 femmes pour six hommes
la gente féminine à des postes à
responsabilité un bon match étant très
bien mais pour quel salaire
en france quand un homme gagne 3000
euros brut une femme gagne 2500 44 euros
bruts ses proches de la moyenne
européenne mais l'écart salarial est
beaucoup plus petit en roumanie en
italie et au luxembourg
la france ne fait donc pas figure
d'exemple reste les avancées sociétales
pour les femmes
simone veil at-elle fait de son pays un
précurseur en la matière
sa loi sur les vg date de 1974 certes
mais avant cela des pays comme la suède
le royaume uni ou encore la finlande
avait déjà autorisé l'avortement
donc si on parle de féminisme
ce que dit jean michel bancaire est
plutôt fou
voilà jacek saryusz wolski vous
réagissiez la pologne est à la pointe du
féminisme dit en partant de marie curie
sklodowska nous avons dans notre culture
un tel respect pour les femmes que
certains disent qu une sommaire
matriarcat est sérieusement il faut dire
que la pologne se place très haut
juste derrière scandinave s'il s'agit de
la position dans la vie sociale et
professionnelle et fait des femmes des
femmes ou sera paritaire dans génération
le moment de benoît hamon
oui d'ailleurs j'espère que la pologne
défendra aussi bien les les droits des
femmes sur toutes les questions et pas
uniquement sur l'égalité salariale même
si elles évidemment fondamental et
notamment sur la question de
l'avortement mais il majorité des femmes
polonais c'est contre oui oui oui mais
je pense quand même qu'il ya un vrai
débat là dessus qu'on pourrait avoir sur
la crise on regarde et on n'est pas très
paritaire là donc on voit bien que on a
encore bien des progrès à faire
la question de l'égalité femmes hommes
c'est pas une question simplement pour
les femmes
la réalité c'est qu'il n'y a pas
d'égalité entre les citoyens si il y à
une différence de genre qui est aussi
accentué donc en fait c'est un combat
pour l'égalité en général c'est ça qui
fortifient sera le mot de la fin merci à
ou trois d'avoir accepté mon invitation
c'était c'était passionnant merci à vous
de nous avoir suivis rester avec nous
sur les chaînes parlementaires et la
rtbf bail
[Musique]